- [Instructor] Let's
discuss interest groups
and as you can see here, it
is one of the three parts
of the iron triangle that we first studied
when we looked at the bureaucracy
in the executive branch.
And the whole point of the
iron triangle is to show
how these different parties
can influence each other.
And so just as a reminder,
an interest group
is any collection of folks who organize
in order to advocate for
something in public policy.
This could be groups of corporations.
It could represent an industry.
It could represent a social cause.
And we're going to look at
some major interest groups
in the United States in a few minutes,
but some can be quite large
and some can be quite small.
But what you see from the iron triangle
is how these parties can
influence each other.
An interest group can
give electoral support
to a member of Congress
by getting its members
to go out and vote for
that member of Congress,
or maybe even doing advertising
for that member of Congress
or giving direct financial support.
In exchange, they might
get friendly legislation
and oversight, and that'll happen
because a congressperson
who got that support
from the interest group
might have a friendly ear
to that interest group and might be open
to hanging out with lobbyists
from that interest group.
The term lobbyist, or lobbying
is believed to originate
in 17th century England where people
who wanted to influence
members of Parliament
would hang out in the lobby
of the parliamentary building
waiting to talk to those
members of Parliament.
And that's what essentially
lobbyists do today.
They try to meet with congresspeople
or meet with the staff of congresspeople
and try to influence the types of bills
that are introduced to
Congress for consideration
and how various members
should vote for those bills.
Now bureaucracy, these are the folks
who for the most part are doing the work
of actually running the government
and they have influence
and they can dictate
what regulations are going to be,
who gets various contracts,
and so you can imagine
that might be of interest
to interest groups.
Now to make tangible what some
of these interest groups are,
you have entities like the AFL-CIO,
which stands for the
American Federation of Labor,
Congress of Industrial Organizations.
And this is a meta organization
of a bunch of labor unions
and as you can imagine
they are going to advocate
for labor-friendly policies.
It might be things that favor
the manufacturing industry
or that favor employees' rights
to collectively negotiate
with their employer.
It might be advocating for trade policies,
which would be perceived as more friendly
to the American worker.
Its membership is roughly
12.5 million people
and so just getting them out to vote
can have a significant
influence on elections.
You have groups like the
U.S. Chamber of Commerce
and what's interesting
here, this membership
of over 300,000, this
isn't just individuals.
This includes corporations.
Even though the Chamber of Commerce
does not have the biggest
budget of the groups
we're gonna look at, it
is actually consistently
the biggest lobbying group,
spending most of this money on lobbying.
And they're going to try to advocate
for business-friendly
policies in our government.
You have groups that
advocate for social causes
like the NAACP, they
don't have a huge budget
but they are considered
very, very influential
when it comes to issues
surrounding minority rights.
You also have very influential groups
like the National Rifle Association.
And when we compare the NRA
to some of these other groups
it's interesting to think
about the number of issues
they concentrate their efforts on.
For example, the Chamber of Commerce
might be thinking about a very broad array
of policy decisions that
might affect commerce,
that might affect businesses,
while the National Rifle
Association and its members,
and this is a significant membership here,
is likely to be much more
focused on a narrower set
of issues around gun
rights and gun ownership.
You have the American Medical Association,
which despite its relatively
small membership here
is highly, highly influential
because these 240,000 people
are for the most part physicians,
who many of us are very
used to listening to.
You have the American Association
for Retired Professionals
which has a membership
of 37 million people
and a budget of 1.6 billion.
So these entities can be very large
and very, very influential.
Now as I mentioned, not
all of these dollars
go directly to lobbying.
They could be spending
money on voter education.
money on legal funds
to advocate for cases that
are in their interest.
They could be giving direct support
to various candidates
or to various parties.
They could be advertising in
the media for their cause.
But if we think about directly lobbying,
this chart right over
here is quite interesting.
It comes from OpenSecrets.org
and if you're really intrigued
by understanding more of
how money and influence
come together in American politics
I encourage you to go to their site.
But this is a list in
2017 of the top spenders
in lobbying in the United
States, and as I mentioned
you see here at the top the
U.S. Chamber of Commerce
at $82 million, and
this isn't even the most
they've ever spent in a year.
There's some years where it
is well over $150 million
that they've spent.
The National Association of Realtors,
the Business Roundtable,
Pharmaceutical Research
and Manufacturers of America.
And this money is, for the
most part, to pay lobbyists
who will meet with
members of our government
to directly advocate for certain policies.
Now an interesting thing to think about is
what positive things might
be done by interest groups,
and what potentially negative
things might be there
and how equitable is this system?
The positive things, folks
could argue, are hey,
they could work on voter education.
Many issues that policy
makers are trying to decide on
are quite complex, so it might be good
to have experts weighing
in, but on the other hand,
it might seem like money is
disproportionately influential
and that industries that
generate a lot of money
could have a disproportionate
amount of influence
and they could potentially
use that influence
to further benefit those industries
to give them even more
power and influence.
So I will let you decide.